[Music]
the annual Academy of Country Music
Awards may have been postponed until
September 16 due to the corona virus
pandemic but that didn't stop the live
performances from taking place during
the show's original time flock more than
20 country artists joined forces Sunday
evening for a two hour television
special featuring acting performances
intimate conversations and a look back
at past ACM Awards moments with Gayle
King serving as host Sunday's show
reminded us all the important healing
power that music has especially in times
like ease I sit on this porch and I've
done a lot of healing a lot of thinking
right here and I actually got married
right here my husband was supposed to
film this but he's fishing at the pond
and I figure for a new york city boy you
better learn how to fish so I'll let him
do that
[Music]
following touching performances from
Dierks Bentley Florida Georgia line
Little Big Town and many more a trio of
superstars closed up the show with a
powerful tribute to Kenny Rogers who
passed away on March 20th at the age of
81 Brad Paisley and Darius Rucker
honored Kenny's long legacy in country
music with a virtual performance of his
hip like the feel and the gambler and
Lionel Richie closed up the tribute with
a reflection on their friendship which
began when Lionel rode Kenny's famous
1980s head lady not only did we have a
hit record but I found one of the
greatest friends I ever had in my whole
life the loss of him is tremendous on my
heart the memory the memories it's
unbelievable we live so much life
together and tonight I want to celebrate
his life
and I want to say to all of his fans he
enjoyed the ride